Transcriber: Bashar Al-Thawabta
المدقّق: Yasmeen Elsayed
أهلاً بكم فى مؤتمر TEDX.
انا أسيا،
عمري 11 سنة، في الصف السادس.
أحب الأشغال اليدوية
والرسم والتزلج بحذاء التزلج.
سوف نتكلم اليوم عن الكرتون.
كل الأطفال يحبون الكرتون.
لأنه دائما يكون وسيلة ترفيهية جاذبة للطفل
مع أنه أحيانا
يتضمن اشياء غير منطقية ابدا.
سوف أعرض عليكم بعض الأمور المربكة
تقريبا لم ينتبه لها أحد.
البط ياكل دجاج!
يشتعل به النار تحت البحر ولا يحدث له شئ.
كيف لم تسقط النظارة من على عينيه؟
هنالك بحر بقاع البحر
بالإضافة إلى نار مشتعلة!
الجاذبية تعمل عندما تنظر للأسفل فقط.
أمر طبيعي أن نسمع من أعيننا.
الإسفنجة تغسل مواعين بأيديها.
من الطبيعي أن تكون سلطعون وتنجب حوتًا.
الفأر يجر كلب.
بالمناسبة يا بطوط، أنت طوال الوقت
لا تلبس بنطال، ولم نعلق عليك.
كيف لم تسقط عصي الأكل من يديها؟
الشعر جزء من الجمجمة.
ألأحدكم أدنى فكرة كيف يدخل راسه
في القميص؟
كل المتزوجون يشبهون بعضهم كأنهم توأم.
كلبين بنفس الكرتون،
واحد يتكلم والثاني حيوانه الاليف.
من حق كل كلب أن يملك كلب.
رغم أنه طول الوقت لا يلبس ملابس،
إلا أنه يخجل عندما يتحمم.
السنافر غير قادرة على الخروج من السجن.
لا يلبسون الملابس إلا على البحر فقط.
من أين يسمع؟
هذا يجعلنا نسأل سؤال مهم جدا،
هل من الممكن للكرتون أن يكون
وسيلة تعليمية قبل أن يكون وسيلة ترفيهية؟
هل يمكن من خلاله تطوير مهارات الأطفال ؟
أنا أحلم عندما أكبر أن أكون
مصممة أفلام كرتون.
أصمم شخصيات منطقيه فيها إبداع تجذب الأطفال
ويكون كارتون له أهداف.
يعلمهم التسامح والحب
والرحمة وكل الصفات الحميدة.
وكرتون ثاني يعلمهم الفنون المختلفة.
وكرتون للبرمجة وكرتون للروبوتيكس.
كل هذا عن طريق قصص شيقة ومبدعة.
أريد أن أصمم شخصية رياضية
تشجع الأطفال على الرياضة والحركة.
ويكون أيضا هنالك كرتون يعلمهم الرياضيات
واللغات والعلوم المختلفة.
أول ما اكتشفت شغفي
كنت أرسم الشخصيات على الورق.
بعدها تطورت وصممت شخصيات بسيطة.
وصممت ألعاب، والآن أطور نفسي في
تصميم الشخصيات.
أنا أسعى لتحقيق حلمي.
وقريبًا سأكون قد حققت جزءًا من أهدافي.
شكرًا لاستماعكم.
(تصفيق)